so hello under a dev summit and welcome
to the support library guts and glory my
name is Chris Bane's and I'm an engineer
on the developer relations team I've
been at Google now for roughly four
years always working on support
libraries and I'm adding power you may
have seen me earlier this morning I've
been at Google for five six years now
working on the Android UI toolkit and
framework right so when we when I first
slide think about this talk it was
originally gonna be like a deep dive on
sort of the internals the sources and
support libraries how we've implemented
them and all that kind of stuff but then
I realized that there's a lot of
developers out there that don't actually
know some of the basics how we actually
architect it sort of how you actually
use it and what you would use it so
we've got these five questions of why
around the support library sort of what
it is why you use it some of the
implications of using it how and then
sort of bugs so let's first talk about
what it actually is yeah sure
so what's included the support library
started out as this very small component
we had this support v4 jar it was a very
simple piece no resources just a little
bit of code that you could add into your
applications and it provided some extra
stuff that you can statically link into
your applications to gain more
functionality over time it's grown it's
grown into a number of other libraries
so saying the Android support library
hasn't really been accurate for several
years now and so we've started growing
all these extra features we've started
adding resources and today this is
really an integral part of building any
modern Android application so the rough
layout or diagram of how the support
libraries look today look something like
this so off to one side we have a series
of feature libraries that are really
pretty standalone they don't
have a whole lot of extra
interdependencies we've got stuff like
the new custom tabs library for browsers
to use we have grid layouts card view
stands on its own and we have the pallet
library for extracting information from
images there are probably a few more in
there but this kind of gives you the
basic idea we have the core that is
still this basic support v4 library that
we have from the very beginning now this
really provides a number of API shims
for newer api's that have been added to
the platform since a given release a lot
of people who ask ok well where did yv4
where does this come from well it comes
from what the min SDK level is for your
application when you use this library so
we support all the way back to donut
which is I understand so has many users
today that way so again we've had some
some legacy in here and you'll start to
see that in this in some of this as well
some of the reasons for the design of
the support library and kind of how it's
grown it's grown very organically so in
addition to API shims for new things
we've got back ports of several items so
for example the fragment library from
the fragment system that was introduced
in android 3.0 honeycomb is available to
all applications even before that as and
again we have a large large number of
users on devices that old these days
however the fragment support library has
kept up to date with newer features such
as embedded child fragments and similar
features we've got other standalone
features things like a view pager you'll
recognize view pager from any sort of
tabbed UI across Android these days
this component doesn't actually have a
representation in the android framework
as a public API instead this just exists
as part of the support library that you
can use anywhere this is a feature
that's become very stable over time on
top of the support v4 libraries and sort
of the infrastructural shims that they
support
you've got items like recyclerview so
you just sat through a wonderful
presentation one recycler view here
recyclerview internally uses a lot of
those api shims to access functionality
that may or may not be available under
the hood it's this sort of layering that
we've really tried to set up across some
of the support libraries so far going a
step further
we have some polyfills so we have
backported large chunks of the UI
toolkit as it's advanced forward in
terms of material design and even holo
before it in the form of the app compat
library now this really tries to track a
lot of the other framework changes that
have had so that just sort of fills in
any missing functionality in older
version to the platform now with that as
a base we've built some other components
that sit on top of these layers we have
things like media router which services
all of the cast endpoints for talking to
chromecast devices and similar we have
the design libraries which provide all
sorts of modern material design
components on top of the basis that app
compat is created we have Preferences
system which updates the Preferences
system that you know and love from the
android framework to also work on other
form factors and we've got the Leanback
library which allows you to create great
10-foot UI experiences so why do we have
all this well part of this was about the
release cycle so we wanted to be able to
do some unbundled releases and get more
of these features out to developers
sooner we also wanted to be able to get
bug fixes out on an app developers
schedule not on a platform release
schedule and we also wanted to make new
features available kind of in between
these releases as well so in this case
static libraries really were the tool to
use here you as the app developer are in
ultimate control of when you update this
code however that also means that you
don't automatically take advantage of
updates and bug fixes that are released
perhaps off cadence from your own app
releases so it's double-edged yes
hopefully over the past sort of glorious
days you've seen that we've been doing
more and more interim releases so
previously the support library is always
tied to platform list but since 21 I
think was the last one and we've been
doing more and more interim releases and
that's because the lot of support
libraries become more and more important
to you guys which means that we need to
start fixing things quicker and we know
that
so recyclerview is one example of the
components that we've got in here again
you just sat through a whole talk based
on that alone we've got data set
windowing within a larger data set and
improves upon similar framework
components
just ListView and it also supports
nested scrolling by way of the v4 Shem
API is that we've made available so just
a quick run-through since you just saw a
bunch of this content plug the talk that
was here before if you missed it go
ahead and go watch the video animations
are a prime example of something that we
were able to offer in recyclerview that
we couldn't necessarily back port to
existing versions of ListView being able
to make this available to previous
platform versions was one of the reasons
recyclerview is developed in the manner
that it was it's pluggable so you can
provide your own your own components and
pieces layout managers item decorations
treatment of recycled view pools all the
complexity that you may want to add to
this or not and it really tries to
enforce some better practices that built
up around something like ListView
overtime app compat that can pop so I'll
compare yeah so this is the thing I've
been working on since I joined Google
it's my starter project actually and
it's generally trying to be a massive
polyfill over the UI toolkit
now as the UI talk it's changed over the
different platform releases we tried the
app compat up to date so originally
started out as a action bar and I'm sure
you were all using the action bar
Sherlock at a time
now and many questions why we actually
released maximum or compact which was
this and now the reason why we did that
is so that we can give you what it is
today so that's a base that we built and
now we've kept it at the framework and
so yeah it backports framework features
but one people know it goes no further
it will never add new features that
aren't in the framework and its goal is
that always to stay up with the
framework estelle today with the
framework we may be a release or two
behind but with those interim releases
that we talked about earlier we will
never be too far so there are three main
things which I think are compact gives
you the first is is themes it gives you
one theme to extend or use which works
and look to mostly the same across all
different ipi levels so that's including
gingerbread for it's a hollow through
some material it gives you one theme to
use
second is toolbar now as we said earlier
there's we give you the action bar in
ipi 11 but it was always these black box
like you couldn't really control it you
can animate it isn't you never really
had any much control over it so toolbar
isn't the manifestation of that as an
actual widget you control it from top to
bottom where it is in your hierarchy you
can animate it you can scroll it you can
do what we want with it
and secondly tinting it's probably on
top of this but enmity not material we
view these pneumatic views wick which
can control them look and feel of your
app for its colors and stuff now how
compact tries to do that as well using
its own attributes there are certain
things which before lollipop don't quite
work and so it's really important to
test and make sure it does so we'll move
on to the design library which is kind
of the Larry above app compat and which
means it goes beyond the framework and
even in design library stuff that isn't
in the framework
it's a UI feature library which tries to
implement material design interactions
and so the stuff what we think is stable
and that are good interactions to use
more specifically the design library
offers us an outlet for all these
components that may have sort of a
fashion lifecycle associated with them
you can probably think of a number of
components over the years that we've
introduced that maybe haven't stood the
test of time some of these components in
the android framework today have been
marked as deprecated such as Android
widget and then some similar things that
you may be able to recall this basically
gives us an ability to still iterate
follow some of these other trends as
they move forward but still give you
something that you can reasonably rely
on so there's full things which I think
design elaborate gives you the high
value stuff basically flex an action
button is probably the most ubiquitous
one it's the thing where you think
material design it's that's certainly
button now there are some nuances of how
it sort of UX back is done just thrown
action button actually does for you and
it's just an image button though right I
mean how hard my it's just yeah the
shadows really
so let's get going on that so one being
you probably don't notice is that
there's actually a small little sheen on
the PHAB and tell me about week to
implement say it's about to use it's
really easy you put this into your
layout and you can change the icon which
is displayed and there's some of the
stuff you can do as well but the
floating action button handles certain
stuff like it has the correct show and
hide animation
it handles itself nicely with snack bar
it's this koala from charity build
straight into it secondly is navigation
view now the material design is quite
specific descriptive over how the side
nav is displayed and how its laid out
and then we've tried to be this is all
stock off-the-shelf component which you
can drag straight into draw layout and
it just works here's what isn't your
layout it's pretty easy there's two
things you can look at the first is
header layout so that is the sort of
header it's a link to it's a reference
to another layout which will be
displayed as a header usually a bit like
something like I can't switch here some
kind of branding the second thing is
menu so that is actually what gets
populated into the navigation view now
we're using menu because it's something
you've already used it's been there as
I've got one you probably use it for
options menu or I can't stuff so you
know exactly how to use it
more specifically it's declarative so
it's easy for tools to access exactly
snap-off which is the kind of new wait
to show temporary information it's been
different to toast it and that allows
you to add an action to it and also it's
swappable there's a small thing here
where you can see that the fab moves up
as the snack bar comes in and that's all
inbuilt functionality that just happens
automatically see you and then lastly
this tab layout now there are two types
of tabs which is called mouthful so this
fixed tabs on the Left where each tab
takes the same out space and I great for
when you have like a small number of a
small number of tabs so you know there's
me three or four they're gonna fit on
the right you've got scrollable so
therefore like four times when you have
like an unknown number so teaching your
layout again tab layout the attribute
here is to look at these tab mode and
you can switch between
scrollable and fixtures
now that we know that most people using
tablet are going to use with a viewpager
so we have this method set up with new
pager which handles all of it for you
populates the tab layout
it sets the listeners so they all Dean
strap interact together wears quite
nicely alright so we've added some other
things more recently as well
inspired by Android wear and really
trying to get a lot of other
proportional layouts on a very small
screen we've got several variants on
existing layout managers that have been
in the framework for a while that now
accepts percentages as well as seaton to
standard measurements that you know and
love so we've got frame layout and
relative layout here and you can define
sizes of elements as a percentage of
their parent rather than just as wrap
content or specific sizes this differs
from weight in a few important ways just
in terms of how it adds up over time as
elements come and go so weight it's
oftentimes a little bit awkward to go
ahead and sort of remeasure and rethink
how some of the stuff would layout
whereas the percentage makes it much
easier to express in line so this adds a
couple of specific layout params
attributes that you'll want to know
about they work about how they sound
like they should from the description so
we have some gotchas in the support
libraries no no never so when you're
building against the support library is
the library major version number really
is the minimum compile SDK version that
you need to declare this is something
that trips up a number of developers and
this is something that isn't always
clear just from the outset we get a lot
of variance on this question as people
move over to a new release of the
support libraries hey my builds broken
why this is probably why so as we
increment the library major version
number you also need to compile against
the latest SDK in addition to that if we
just leaked IPL 24 there's there's gonna
be an API 20 for everybody you heard it
here first
so this is another number that you're
probably familiar with not only is it a
handy dandy power-of-two it's also the
Dex method reference limit so how big
are all these support libraries anyway
well app compat is kind of a few in
terms of that method get' v4 library
okay
well that's that's a little bit bigger
design library and zuy a recycler view
hmm okay well that's kind of a big
number and that's also a lot to ask
developers to devote to some of these
components you know sorry one thing to
notice there is that that's a ferret or
maximum and they will actually be
scintilla counting that number as well
just because like those support
libraries will be reference in framework
methods now if you use those same
methods they won't be counted to us
right so there's a little bit of folding
that happens here but it also starts
incrementing the count pretty pretty
quickly so many of you have probably
already figured out that you can use
handy-dandy ProGuard tools to take care
of some of this problem and you can set
minimize minify enabled to true across
the android support package and well
that's a little bit more manageable than
what we had before of course the more of
the support libraries you use the more
you're going to be pulling in the
chi-square example app so far we were
able to cut down over half of that and
it still uses a fair number of the
pieces of functionality available yeah
wanted to know that is that that is the
very basic ProGuard config like you
could go further into that and start
stripping more stuff that's right so of
course pro-gard isn't optimal especially
when you're in a sort of very tight
modify compile debug run test type of
development cycle at that point you'll
have plenty of time to check your
favorite social media sites before that
gets done and installs on your device
however I think that there was this
really cool demo earlier this morning
that might be able to help out with some
of that now that we have the the new
features in studio to shorten that cycle
that'll help out with this as well
so whereas before it wasn't really
something that you wanted to do to
enable this type of stripping just
straight out of the box on every build
now it's at least a little bit more of a
palatable option if your app
I'm starting to get large so one thing
that one sort of strategy of her from
sort of you guys really is that most
engineers will use multi decks for
day-to-day development Duke cities click
on pro guard for the debug build and
then when you ask you want to release
that's when you turn on pro guard and so
that's tend to be strategy which sounds
like you should work well yeah I mean it
comes along with other costs as well
like especially if you're doing any sort
of optimization of startup time that
comes with some other costs as well
anyway there's a lot of trade-offs but
there are options available so don't
think that you're stuck when you run up
against some of these problems and one
thing to actually say that we know that
this is a problem like we know that
support before is quite large and we are
thinking of ways to improve the
situation like we don't the short
version of it is we're gonna delete a
lot of code okay so how how are we gonna
delete a lot of code no how do we use
how do we use it so we all I'm guessing
we can grade all these days and so you
just add the library to your dependency
but one thing I've seen sort of been
quite a lot of open source apps is that
you're we be using more than one support
library and then you'll forget to update
the version number on one of them and
then I'll get our sink and then bad
stuff can happen so is this just a small
tip and I'm sure most you're using this
anyway is that you can extract the
version number into a variable in your
Gradle file and then you can use it you
can replicate in that dependency line so
after that it actually clicks okay your
dependencies come this what it means is
that whenever you want to update your
version number when you have a little
loops the new version at the support
library you can change this one line it
works for everything else it means
you're gonna hit less problems and also
so less time money editing rate of files
but you know everyone wants to spend
last time there
okay so bugs in the support libraries
never ebooks no so what you want half of
this we know there are bugs there are
always gonna be bugs in the support
library just because that just the
nature of what it is we have to support
all the way back to API version forms
and support we for I can pass me seven
all the others so there are there are
sometimes gonna be bugs we know that
so we are very grateful for when you
actually submit stuff and hope you'll
see that we're pretty hot in it like we
will assign stuff pretty quickly and
even though we don't release as quickly
as what some of you would like we know
that it's something that we should
improve and this is something where
we've got a number of things in progress
we have heard you we got a lot of
feedback from the last couple releases
that we had that were maybe a little bit
rougher than we would have preferred and
we're working on it so this is something
that if there's some more stuff that we
miss please submit them we this is not
just a black box that you're gonna throw
stuff throw reports down into and we
won't read we do keep an eye on these
things won't Peter knows well actually
when you open the book on AOSP and
there's a there's a little box at the
top which allows you to change what type
of book we need to select support
library it'll come with a template
please follow the template for things
like design library where a lot of the
books tend to be scrolling and you
trying to describe in text isn't gonna
really like it doesn't help me and
you've given me a screen record of how
it actually looks he's much easier for
me to actually debug and work out what's
happening and it just saves me time and
it's safe for you guys town as well
alright so we have saved plenty of time
because support library is one of those
topics that everybody has something to
talk about for it so we like to open up
the floor to Q&A
could be don't know boom we've got one
over here and one over here we have the
mics up okay they're coming
hi so we have the very nice floating
action button in this design library is
the floating action button menu coming
soon Jimmy lot speed our lot in box
style sorry Jimmy like speed dial the
inbox style of when he pops it with a
little magic yeah the plus that changes
into a cross and pops up the items
awesome the design team is playing
around with a bunch of other ideas
around this one of the things that tends
to happen especially with the design
library is well let me back up for a
second we mentioned before that when we
put a component into the AOSP support
libraries we really want it to be
something that we're fully real willing
to endorse this particular pattern a lot
of the Google applications such as inbox
have done a bunch of their own
explorations down one path or another
that kind of extends some of these basic
ideas so far the design team hasn't been
willing to entirely put their stamp of
approval on this to the point of saying
hey we want to see this in every Android
app and we think that this is this and
all of the details behind this pattern
or something that we want to really
standardize on and give to developers as
this this is sort of full story for the
platform so as soon as that happens
you'll see this showing up in the design
support library yeah I mean if you look
at this material design spec it's it
doesn't really mention the speedo
anymore it mentions it's quite general
like transitions I think they call it so
we are looking at writing some the
transitions between things but it's
still a days we're not there yet
don't say watch this space got one a
print or another
what's your policy on on trying to
resolve or if you want to try to resolve
crashes to come up from manufacturers
such as Samsung or HTC that's my fella
so believe what it is that you're
referring to is that on some devices
that are out there there is a
potentially older version of support
libraries that are on the default class
path this is something that we're
working with manufacturers on to to try
and help with this and in the meantime
we're gonna offer some other workarounds
that'll hopefully make your lives as
developers a little bit easier with like
the Gradle build tool or some of the
other libraries in there they're not got
maven repo online or anything else and
the support libraries you have to
download it to your local machine and
trying to keep that up to date on this
been very frustrating and hard at times
as their way like move that to a
centralized repo we can just get access
to or so I think that's probably a good
question for some of the Android tools
team they'll be outside available at the
probably the kiosk that says Android
studio also probably a great question to
bring up at like the fireside chat
around tools as well
I did any plans of bringing animations
to gridview similar to recyclerview to
grid view similar to a recycler view I
believe that the plan on that is to
build more grid layout managers for
recyclerview so that it inherits all the
animation capabilities that recyclerview
has a grid view right now is based on
the same internals that ListView is
within the framework and for all the
same reasons it's basically hid its
complexity budget in terms of this
there's a number of tactics that you can
use to try to do similar animations in
grid view and in list view and all of
them end up having some pretty drastic
downsides to them in terms of what
you're able to do from from application
code or from something like a support
library in there so we would really
suggest using a recycler view layout
manager meant to layout within a grid to
get that type of functionality
yeah there's already two top of my head
there's really two greedy layout
managers bundled with Misaka with you
there's Groot layout manager and there's
staggered grid lab manager and they both
do slightly different things in terms of
how they deal with spacing but yeah
they're already there so you can look so
recycler view is its own standalone
component and has its own standalone
library where is like you mentioned
before something like view pager which
doesn't exist in the framework but it's
just part of the core in the future can
we expect to see things like that that
aren't in the framework but are
standalone in their own libraries you
also saw this with grid layout as an
example of something else that kind of
sat on its own most of the reason for
this is kind of historical we started
off with the v4 support library and due
to some limitations in our internal
build tools at the time this was all
like pre Gradle Prix ARS things like
that
we couldn't have resources in there so
we had a bunch of other pieces I mean
this is part of the reason why you can't
do nice things with attributes and your
layouts for things like viewpager
whereas if we were doing that today we
would totally add all these additional
pieces so now we basically have this
this issue of like keeping source
compatibility with a lot of current
developers builds and so on and so forth
around that I think that the design
library approach is probably the one to
expect with things with a Ford facing UI
component recyclerview is a little bit
unique in the it's basically a framework
for writing list views and to that end
it kind of sits in on its own just
because it's a little bit more
infrastructural instead of the full
out-of-the-box turnkey component I would
probably expect to see some things based
on recyclerview start making their way
into some other libraries that kind of
sit on that layer of abstraction above
the backward he makes huge use of
wristlock with you that's a perfect
example yeah
hi any plans or suggestions for doing
animations and view pagers let's
specifically like remove into add
animations there that's also a great
question so I've kind of had this idea
kicking around my head for a while that
at some point a viewpager would be
updated into sort of the new world into
kind of a new view page or two based on
top of recycler view in which case again
just just like with grid views you'd
kind of inherit a lot of that
functionality for free we haven't gotten
around to doing that sort of thing yet
but if you were feeling so inclined to
build something kind of like that and
you feel like you want to take a crack
at it
that's probably how I would start in
terms of view pagers current system of
what types of animations are you
thinking of I mean we do have a little
bit of capability in there around the
lines of like Page transformers and that
allows you to get kind of the what we
always called the cafeteria tray style
that we used to use in the the paged
launcher all apps a couple of versions
ago you can also use it to to get quite
a few other effects as you're paging
through things so what were you thinking
of more specifically oh sorry they took
your mic
specifically actually add and remove
animations so removing pages from it and
also being maybe this is a little bit
too far out but be far out come on being
like being able to fling multiple pages
but land on page boundaries I see yeah
this is it huh it sounds like gallery
yeah it actually does it so we have this
wonderful deprecated widget in the
framework that you can take a look
no so again this is one of those
features that's kind of a kind of a
well-known feature request for a
recycler view in general which is being
able to stop on item detent boundaries
this is something that a number of teams
have wanted for a number of other types
of applications but the core piece of
functionality remains the same for all
of it it's just kind of like that
spin it around along the other axis of
scrolling and make the item sizes either
uniform or not it all kind of boils down
to the same thing in the end so that's
something that we're definitely thinking
about in terms of recyclerview as an
infrastructure component anyone else
hello could we expect some of the
material spec components to be added
anytime soon something like the bottom
sheet maybe yes
so bottom sheets a weird one in that
there's two types of bottom sheets from
what I remember the spec they're not too
prescriptive over what the content is
it's more the interaction so the thing
that we'll be concentrating on is the
interaction because that's probably the
most difficult thing to get right so
that might be coming soon yeah so
Krista's being very cagey basically I
would say that in the fullness of time I
think it's our ideal that the design
work library would reflect to the
contents of the material design spec the
important bits the behind the stuff
you're going to use so the parts we like
yeah well the stuff that we want them to
use yes all of it I guess okay
I I'm wondering if there are any plans
for like supporting font features in the
support libraries so on newer versions
of Android there's the Roboto font so
for example in a navigation view for
example in a spec it's supposed to be a
medium font which does not exist on
older API levels so or like in the
toolbar so are there any plans for
supporting fonts and that kind of thing
you went to race talked earlier didn't
you on the typography yeah
so yeah that was that was a good piece
of feedback especially from from within
that talks Q&A as well so thank you for
that we'll try and make that a little
bit more extensible at least so that you
can get those sorts of things plumb down
into those widgets that do sort of
generate their own items that contain
text I think that's a great piece of
feedback one of the other things that
some people found pretty pretty early
after the introduction of the data
binding system and this may not apply
esses airily to like the navigation view
or toolbar issues that you're bringing
forth here but with regard to other font
features people found that they could
use a couple little snippets of code
within the data binding system to apply
some pretty interesting font tricks to
existing views so I would probably use
your favorite search engine and try and
dig up some of those posts and and take
a look at some of the stuff that they've
done because it really does help to fill
some of those gaps around font features
in particularly we've got one back here
I really like the nested it's a
necessarily in concept that we are like
we're seeing now so my question is do
you have any tips or tricks on
developing debugging testing like code
that's related to gesture handling
because there was a bug and this is
scrolling I think in the recyclerview
and that was that was really difficult
to debug if I read the man who wrote
Misty's colon was here oh now you're
just reusing Chet's jokes good so which
which bug are you referring to I mean I
guess yes it can't it can definitely be
a little bit a little bit brain bending
to deal with the nested scrolling stuff
as part of the reason why we're trying
to make it a little bit a little bit
more turnkey in general just with some
of the components that are part of the
design library and so on and so forth so
what were some of those specific issues
that you ran into and we can try and
take that into account for the future
well the example was it was well you're
fleeing a recycler there cycle of you
and I had another fit but basically
implementing my parallax effect for
example the fling was actually the
Felina was that the velocity I was sent
to the view that's being parallax
animated was the wrong direction things
like that and it was it was like when
you scroll thing and when you fling it
it was like it was moving it along
nicely nicely and then it just went to
the bouncing back the completely
opposite direction yeah we see in the
chi-square if you haven't tried the
latest version of recyclerview or other
support v7 mm-hmm libraries but
supposedly it's fixed I haven't tried it
yet though we know the issue just
wondering like do you have any tips and
tricks in terms of when it develop this
kind of things so the difficulty with
debugging this kind of stuff is when you
start moving the view at the same time
so that's when it gets a little
difficult which is why this this
particular book has been quite hard to
track down
we think we're there now we think yeah
we think with that basically being cagey
about it but yes we were actually
looking at exactly this problem last
week yes
this bug in particular so yes we're
sorry that's one of things with mrs.
golden actually because I mean the IPR
is great but each of you which
implements it does it slightly
differently so that's one the written
the reason for these kind of issues
still crop up because I mean some of
this just kind of owes to the way that
the recyclerview is a really great
example of this I mean if if one piece
of scrolling code covered every possible
use case then we would have been done
with scroll view so recycler view and
other things scroll by completely
different mechanisms for one reason or
another and it ends up leading to bugs
that hopefully you never see externally
and unfortunately this one made it out
anyone else
not
I think my mullet going once going twice
okay okay thank you very much